[Music]
ever wondered how actors safely jump and
punch through glass windows and movies
it's all thanks to this specially
engineered prop glass which is made with
weak molecular bonds so that it shatters
easily and spectacularly on camera i
gotta say like that doesn't i mean i
barely feel the impact breakaway glass
is just one type of super specialized
movie prop you might not think about
from fake money to noiseless paper bags
let's start with those noiseless props
[Music]
look at these two paper bags they don't
appear very different but they sound
different one of these is a real
everyday paper bag
and the other one is a silent prop
this fake paper bag was an innovation
thought up by prop maker tim schultz
props is always about solving a problem
and one of those problems is everyday
objects that don't look distracting but
sound distracting i often say that a
sound guy can hear grass growing when
you're on location silencing some props
like drums can be fairly simple like
adding a drum mute
[Music]
but others require getting a bit more
creative
like with pool balls which were too loud
for these two bar scenes in season one
of friday night lights
nice shot
property master scott reader needed to
find a ball that would create a softer
sound on impact first he experimented
with plastic balls from a ball pit they
were much quieter but he couldn't get
paint to stick to the surface then he
remembered a trick he used on 1991's
necessary roughness during a shot where
a character is thrown onto a pool table
in a bar fight reader swapped real pool
balls with racquetballs so the actor
would land on something softer we didn't
really clue in at the time that oh you
know these would be good for sound
listen to how real pool balls sound
it's too noisy compared to the
racquetballs
much better
to get it to look like the real thing
reader added a layer of primer to make
sure the paint stuck followed with a
glossy spray to give off the signature
shine of a real pool ball you gotta pick
them up to tell that they're not real
and reader also had to know when to swap
the props in if actors are playing in a
scene we'll typically do real if the
camera is going to see them hit the ball
and then when the camera goes to where
it's just on their face we'll throw the
fake ones on the table so they can
actually play pool
that way the sound man can catch the
dialogue prop masters don't always need
to find a replacement
some silent props are made by just
modifying the real thing
for example in this scene in tammy
actress melissa mccarthy needed to wear
a paper bag on her head to hide her
identity and another one on her hand to
hide a gun schultz said it was important
for her to use the real thing but a real
paper bag would sound something like
this just get hot you want some pies
get a pile for you get
quieting these real bags down meant
adding more weight to them so schultz
sprayed the bags with a mix of water and
glycerin which is typically used to add
the appearance of sweat or water
droplets on anything from human skin to
beer bottles it takes quite a bit of
time well it takes time and finesse
because you don't want to overdo it
he also taped the bags inside to hold
them together and prevent them from
crumbling but this fix was only
temporary since the bags would
eventually lose their color and fall
apart over time and this wouldn't work
for when actors have to handle bags
consistently so for other projects
schultz developed a quiet durable
alternative using fibrous non-woven
fabric this is actually the same
material as coffee filters to make it
look like the real thing schultz wraps
the fabric around a mold then he glues
and folds the sides by hand we're trying
to copy the bottom of the
of a standard bag that
is really made by a machine it's
important to get the corners so that
they're
square a lot of times we'll
when we're using them we'll crinkle them
and make them look more used
so they have a more realistic look
instead of cutting it smooth
it's going to cut it with a little
jagged edge to it this fabric can be
used on other paper products as well
like when this butcher in the kaminsky
method talks to alan arkin while
grabbing a handful of cold cuts that
butcher paper
fake
it's these small handheld props that
give prop masters the most trouble
especially in scenes with dialogue for
example an actor with a drink will
likely hold it near their midsection
where microphones are often attached
it's especially important to make sure
whatever is in that drink doesn't
produce any unwanted sounds so if you're
watching a show like entourage with lots
of scenes at parties and bars it's safe
to assume that these ice cubes are all
fake
but not all fake ice is the same plastic
cubes don't melt which is great for
continuity but they're still really loud
so when sound is crucial schultz often
opts for another type of fake cubes
these ones made out of silicone
[Music]
these rubber cubes can either be molded
in trays or ripped apart since the final
product floats in a glass they look more
convincing
and best of all they're completely
silent
background actors can move the stuff
around without having to worry about the
sound so when this waitress walks by
with a tray full of cups with ice you
can hear what time's dinner was starving
and not what time's dinner started while
ice cubes only pop up in certain moments
other loud materials are everywhere like
plastic everything from sandwich bags to
potato chip bags make loud crackles so
schultz will create fake ones out of
vinyl so this material
this little sound
and it comes in handy for other places
you might not expect like flower
bouquets that are wrapped in cellophane
take this moment from the kaminsky
method where michael douglas's character
brings flowers to an ailing friend if
schultz had used real cellophane for the
bouquet all the sound team would hear is
what kind of flowers are
i have no idea so he used a transparent
vinyl material to replicate the look
without all the noise
what kind of flowers are those i have no
idea
uh-huh so your daughter bought
yeah
but no solution is one size fits all
noisy tissue
but a quiet bag
still doesn't solve the problem some
objects need multiple layers of silent
material to effectively kill any noise
like with these gift bags
so
quiet tissue
quiet bag
done
so next time you see a scene set in a
grocery store a bar or even just around
the office look twice at the everyday
objects you can see but can't hear
we can all thank the prop makers for
that
[Music]
[Music]
guys i'm at new rule effects and today
i'm going to learn how to make breakable
props for movies and tv shows let's
check it out from sinewy bones to fake
blood to fake weapons new rule effects
provides hollywood with all kinds of
props and effects
but there's one thing they truly
specialize in
breakaway props and effects
the kinds of products you see in a movie
that are meant to be broken this is ryan
johnson he's the owner of new rule
you've seen new rules work in many
places before the fx studio showed us
how breakable props are made
when and how they're used and then they
let us put a few of the coolest products
to the test
it's like getting hit with like a
nerf bat or something
[Music]
to make a breakaway prop they take an
actual object like a glass bottle and
create a mold for it a very hot resin
plastic material is used and is then
poured into a negative
after either a few hours or even a few
days they'll have a hardened vinyl
replica that is light and meant to be
broken
other objects like chairs and cinder
blocks are vacuformed and 3d printed
but why do they shatter so easily they
they break very easily because a they're
very very brittle and they have a very
weak molecular bond so
the molecules in the substance are very
very weak and so it breaks very easy on
any kind of impact
this stuff is designed for absolute
safety
the level of safety that's required on
the set is determined by how the prop is
going to be seen in the film if it's a
bottle that's being broken over a head
for example we have to make sure that
the
the resin is thin enough so it'll break
easily and safely we'll engineer
the prop so that it performs in the way
that's specific to the script
and with that we are ready to try a few
of these out
[Music]
you know
breaks like a bottle as well how about a
heads up next time on that okay heads up
i gotta say like that doesn't i mean i
barely feel the impact yeah they're very
light like if you have a ring okay if
you pop it in the ring first it'll just
literally fall apart okay and you don't
even have to squeeze it that hard but it
just makes it
wild man
go on glug
if like i'm looking at this and i'm like
this looks like glass like i'm still
kind of like afraid to touch it
[Music]
so for a big breakaway window effect
what we usually try to do is actually a
lot of smaller panes that are all glued
together into a balsa wood frame this
might be for a scene in which a
character might have to punch through a
window you have to be a little bit
careful when you're using breakaway
glass especially with the larger pieces
because they are going to break in
really sharp shards but if you just
punch like straight through it it would
you know break
[Music]
now for a scene in which something much
bigger than a fist like a full body or
even a car goes through the glass that
window will be made with tempered glass
which will actually be shattered a
fraction of a second before anything
actually goes through the glass with the
help of a pyrotechnic device
[Music]
all right now go get me the fake one
no that wasn't bad at all actually it
looks like a big salad brick was
actually like a hard sponge
[Music]
that's ridiculous how light this is
[Music]
household products like plates mugs and
vases can also be made to be broken now
there are a few other tricks to make
convincing breakable
objects sometimes they'll use rubber
glass shards those can be used in a
scene where a character has to walk over
glass die hard
[Music]
i tell everybody slow down let every let
the camera capture the action so if you
go a little bit slower you ended up you
end up with bigger shards so
let's slow a few of these down
[Music]
i really enjoyed
smashing things and breaking all the
bricks i learned that
as difficult as they are to make it's a
lot harder to make something that's
breakable it also looks realistic but
there's just something so satisfying
about breaking a bottle a brick or a
chair there was a childhood fantasy come
true
is this food making you hungry
well don't try to take a bite
because these delicious looking foods
are actually fake
[Music]
tv shows and movies will try to use real
foods on screen when possible but there
are a number of reasons why food props
might be used instead for example if ice
cream is used they don't want it to melt
between takes or if you need a lot of
food in the background of a shot
companies like independent studio
services and display fake foods offer
pre-made food props that can be ordered
in bulk but oftentimes movies need items
specially made that's when they seek out
a fake food artist like lisa friedman
for people who need something specific
that's why they reach out to me i'm an
artist i went to school for art and i
also love to cook and bake there's not a
lot of us out there that do this
brenda chapman also makes fake foods in
oklahoma i just kind of figure it out so
i've had no formal training didn't go to
college started this just so i could be
a stay-at-home mom with my kids both
women work out of studios in their homes
they can recreate pretty much anything
much of their day-to-day business is in
restaurant displays and food shows but
prop masters will contact them if they
need food items for movies
in the last 20 years i've done almost
three million dollars worth of fake food
business
brenda has had her work featured in a
number of productions for glee she made
some ice cream for this diner scene the
in their diner scene they wanted
milkshakes and sundaes and banana splits
that were new
half eaten quarter eaten so that they
could switch them out during the the
takes she says you don't always know
where your food will end up like when
some of her items popped up in the
muppets when
miss piggy eats my donuts i didn't
realize that they had bought my donuts
of course
and sometimes your food doesn't even
make the final cut thor actually the
movie actually bought like 500 worth of
donuts and they had a building that said
donut shop or donut plant they never
went inside so i didn't see my donuts it
was very sad
[Laughter]
here's a creamsicle lisa friedman mean
that was featured in a scene from kevin
probably saves the world
the coldest thing they have oh thank you
i guess his eye was swollen he got hit
in it while the details may vary based
on the artist the creation process is
pretty standard we stopped by lisa
freeman's home in new york to see how
she makes her fake foods
after the order is submitted typically
the customer will send her a real
version of the food they want duplicated
then she will produce a mold out of the
item to get the exact size and shape
we try to mold it close to the color so
that we're not starting with a blank
white canvas
typically fake foods are made with
rubber or foam
she pours the material into the mold and
lets it set foam rises like actual dough
so she needs to prevent it from spilling
out it's like i'm baking a cake right
i'm baking my bread
[Music]
then she sands the excess pieces down
once the item is dry it's painted and
detailed to look like real food with my
background in painting
i can color it to be as you know as
realistic as it is
you just kind of have to look at things
a little differently
and think okay it's not made for this
but it does look like this we do use a
lot of styrofoams a lot of um just
stuff from the local hardware store you
know caulking and
drywall uh patching and sheetrock mud to
replicate granola and ground beef lisa
uses crushed corkboard cork is kind of
like breaks up like granola so we took
some cork boards and we started breaking
it down
sometimes real food is used
like covering actual popcorn cereal or
candy in resin to preserve it
it's often hard to tell the finished
product from the original i don't do
this for the money it's kind of more for
the
accolades when my customers write oh i
love it it came out great
and while these items might make your
mouth water they're only a feast for
your eyes
[Music]
what you're seeing here isn't a real
cockroach
it's actually a cleverly disguised date
a trick melissa mcsorely mastered for a
scene from crazy ex-girlfriend where a
character picks up a live cockroach and
eats it whole it's an opportunity to do
something that's out of the normal realm
for me and it gives me an opportunity to
start coming up with ways to tackle it
most props are meant to be picked up and
handled but some need to be consumed
that's where food stylists like melissa
come in and transform seaweed and chili
threads into cockroach legs and antennae
so how can she make everything from live
bugs to guts to blood edible
and do they actually taste good
the seaweed crunch right that's really
smart because it's getting like crunchy
because i got nothing to crunch
food stylists are used to solve problems
like making sure ice cream doesn't melt
or finding a convincing substitute for
runny yolks when it comes to replicating
things one normally wouldn't eat melissa
has to use edible ingredients that
create the same look as the non-edible
prop
like blood
typical fake human blood isn't toxic and
an actor can even have a little around
their mouth
but when melissa worked on true blood
she needed something safe enough for
vampire characters to drink in large
amounts
she started with a mix of cran cherry
and pomegranate juice great for scenes
where a glass or bottle was just sitting
out or being held but she also had to
replicate the true properties of blood
like its opaqueness which is why she
added wheatgrass to her formula and
there isn't just red food coloring in
there i had to add a little blue because
these juices were far more red than
blood would normally be so just had to
tamp it down a little as a former
phlebotomist melissa knew that these
small details would add to the realism
so she also focused on the viscosity of
the blood if it was a scene where you
would see them pick up the glass and
drink and put it down you would want to
see the blood adhere to the side and
slowly go down to achieve this effect
she thickened her concoction with methyl
cellulose and then if someone were to
drink it
you can see that it will slide back down
the side of the glass
cheers
this is really good this is like yeah it
tastes just like a like really fine
juice because it's so thick if i was on
the true blood set they'd have to be
like stop drinking that drink something
else sometimes productions want an
edible prop even if the actors aren't
planning on eating it like this scene
from the amazon series homecoming these
two characters would be handling raw
chicken guts and other foods and objects
at the same time to avoid
cross-contamination on set melissa
created edible and safe chicken guts out
of carefully disguised food while
sausage casings made sense for the
intestines me can easily go bad during
long shoot days so instead she filled
collagen casings with bean curd chicken
blood is also more yellow so she dyed
her ingredients yellow and then switched
to pink as the intestines grew pinker
the further down they go
it's important to use foods that can
take many different shapes and sizes
for example melissa would use ramen or
glass noodles here over spaghetti as
they are more pliable it takes on
different shapes than spaghetti does it
also has different edges to it where
spaghetti is like totally round this is
probably more like a linguine then by
dyeing these turnips different colors
they could stand in for both the heart
and the liver on top of all that you can
see cherry tomatoes and kumquats this is
the kind of detail that could only come
from the close eye of a food stylist so
while i was doing my research i found a
few pictures of hens that actually had
unlaid eggs inside their cavity and they
basically look like a very very orange
organic egg yolk if melissa can't find a
specific food that can stand in for
something else she'll have to make her
edible props from scratch like in this
scene from the netflix series daybreak
where ms crumble eats a handful of live
maggots pulled from the trash in this
shot you see actual live magazines who
were on set with their wrangler and had
to be kept safe so in this shot the
maggot actors were swapped for fake
gummy maggots
i mean i know they're fake but i mean
they look exactly like maggots so
there's a part of me that's just like
you know like especially like when i
look down the ball you got a couple like
stuck to the side there to get the
correct form melissa started off with a
mold of plastic grubs that she found at
a bait and tackle store and they were
very very close in like size and shape
and they had the same ribbing as a
little maggot she filled the mold with
gelatin which made them naturally
wiggling more movement can be added
based on how you hold the bowl full of
them
oh like so it just starts discerning
literally so they kind of start
cascading down whatever even though they
were so tiny they couldn't be uniform in
color over the course of the life of a
maggot they change colors so when you
actually see the maggots in daybreak
you'll see that there's a range going
from translucent to white and then
leaning in towards a beige and then to a
brown
first she had a coconut pudding followed
by caramel coloring and almond milk to
make them darker as they aged wait let
me also act like i'm actually eating
maggots oh if i was like fear fact or
something
yeah this tastes great have you guys had
this they like fruit snacks
the little details melissa had to get
right in each maggot pale in comparison
to the cockroach from crazy
ex-girlfriend edible props are
frequently shown in close-up form
meaning melissa couldn't get away with
using a date on its own it also needed
legs antennae wings and a head
chili threads replicated floppy and tank
and dry seaweed was sturdy enough for
its legs as for the body melissa sorted
through an entire container of dates the
first thing that i look at is the size
and to make sure that it's not too big
or too small for the final cockroach the
second thing that i look for is that
they're not too wrinkled they're not too
shriveled some of them are too broken up
to actually use since the wings need to
be all one piece and look like they're
attached the reason that i picked these
three dates to start with is they're all
about the same uniform size
and the skins are perfectly intact this
allowed her to fillet and flatten the
dates as she noticed that roaches are
typically flatter than that of average
dates so taking out
as much of the meat in the back part of
the date as i can and then that leaves
the wings separate and hollow and then
the second date that we choose is the
one that i use for the head i usually
look for ones that have a little smaller
and pointed top and that are a little
bit darker than the actual cockroach
body we've chosen
meanwhile the natural stickiness of the
dates acted as a glue when piecing the
two together making sure everything fit
together was by choosing the exact right
pieces of seaweed was so crucial it's
just looking for ones that have a slight
curve
to it so that they can actually fit into
the body and leave the legs straight the
monotonous task of choosing the right
strands pays off on cam in the final
shot the flexible chili threads
naturally move with the wind like real
antennae would plus to add the crunch
missing from the date it's so nice i
don't want to ruin it but
gotta do it
[Music]
you see we
also gives it a surprise like
salty fishing stone so even that the
reaction was a bit uh authentic because
i was like i know what dates taste like
and then when i heard the salty
fishy taste of seaweed i'm like oh
it's these minute details that make the
most convincing edible props and get the
best reactions
for judy moody and the not bomber summer
melissa created edible pieces of
bigfoot's poop which the characters
accidentally eat using peanut butter and
chocolate for color and texture seems
obvious but there's more than meets the
eye the nuts are a nice touch well it's
not just poop it's bigfoot poop
so we have to assume bigfoot lives in
the woods yeah nuts and berries i
figured his poop would have been a
little bit bigger also would have
accepted corn
[Music]
oil
it's like a brownie it is a brownie
right
kind of like
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this is the lab basically where we do
all of our
all of our mixing and potioning
so as you can probably tell we've mixed
a few
batches of blood on this counter but
i can take you through
a batch if you like
most of your run-of-the-mill bloods
start off with
corn syrup you know it gives it a little
viscosity if it was going to be a
regular everyday blood we put some soap
in it
because that helps it clean up
oh really like when you when you get in
your wardrobe or something
it helps it wash out if you were to just
put
color in here right now
it would kind of come out looking like
cherry cough syrup because blood is a
little opaque it's not completely
see-through
so we um we add
an opacifier to it to make it opaque
before we start to color it so basically
what you get
is kind of this white looking slurry
then you can start to color it we go
through a lot of food coloring obviously
the base is red now you're never really
going to get to
a really realistic blood red with just
red food color so what we do is we add a
little blue or black and then that gives
us a little depth
so now you know it looks more like your
classic
classic blood
now we can take this
and
take it out here and do a little
something with it if you like
so we can we can do the you know maybe a
blood spray and maybe the um you know
the classic blow out the back your head
on the wall kind of thing if you want
yeah sure for this like sometimes you
know you'd hide them behind somebody and
then um you know at the moment where
they get shot in the head then
splat against the wall
[Music]
now if we do more pressure then it's a
little more violent
wow
that is brutal
[Music]
have you ever been watching something on
tv and thought hey
where'd that dead body come from how
does it look so real and how did it fall
off that tall building we went to dapper
cadaver in los angeles to learn how they
make fake bodies and body parts for tv
and movies
dapper cadaver bills itself as a death
related prop house and prop fabrication
shop if it's dead or can die we can make
it this is bj and eileen winslow
co-owners of the prop house their work
has appeared in many different movies
and tv shows
they showed us how their fake bodies are
made and how they give them such
realistic injuries we also put one of
their creations to the ultimate test
testicle here right yeah that's an
eyeball
no i think it's a testicle okay i'm
scared
[Music]
most of their bodies are made in these
giant molds
they pour the materials usually polyfoam
into a mold hard to believe that this
becomes this
they have molds for just about any kind
of project that gets thrown their way
whichever mold they decide to use
depends on the project they're working
on they even have a pig shaped one in a
butcher shop display
they also specialize in organs which
might appear in an autopsy scene
then they just pop right out of the mold
soon they'll be painted and detailed the
heads are typically life cast from
actual people but are often re-sculpted
and given new features over time
when working with clients sometimes
they'll get a photo of an actor or a
sketch to help make the model but most
of the time they have to work completely
from scratch
once we start changing hair and beard
and skin color like those guys can
really just completely transform from
looking
like
nobody in particular to looking like two
completely different people and you see
an arm painted flesh tone with no
shading on it it looks like a rubber arm
that you would see in a halloween shop
[Music]
they have bodies of all shapes and sizes
like a baby made out of silicone
the material allows it to be more
flexible and more detailed
it's feet this feels like a bait i mean
that's warm but like about the weight of
a baby
not all fake bodies are made in the same
way
so this is our lucy body
she's what we call a half anatomical
which that means that she is she's life
cast from the waist up
and then she is a posable dummy body
from the waist down and that gives her
you know a high degree of both detail
and flexibility
you know for us the sharp shirt is he's
not like the silicone you're going to
want to move it to bend the wire there
you go
besides dressing them there's still a
lot more they have to do with these
bodies to make them look realistic
[Music]
you've got to be imaginative with your
injuries
this body was made to look like it's
succumbed to frostbite
this one got impaled and this one is
just ahead i refer to science books and
anatomy books um you know police
photography and just like anything that
can give me a realistic understanding of
you know anatomy and the processes that
we're working with we both have a
an appreciation and love of science uh
when bj went to college he started
actually both of us started out as
biology majors
he started out in biology i started out
in biophysics and but it's funny because
both of us then ended up in writing
degrees over our college time and so
these days we really get to marry our
love of both biology and storytelling
they're especially good at making a body
look burned
some of their charred bodies popped up
in the revenant they demonstrated this
technique for us using just an arm
they add layers of paint and spray paint
and what happens on top of the burn is
that your skin
gets you know crispy
wrinkle wrinkly starts to
you know de-glove from the hand itself
so to represent that we're just using
ordinary shrink wrap
then they cover it in an ashy looking
burn mud
after that they use a heat gun to shrink
the shrink wrap
that's when the details really come out
this looks incredible look at the detail
on this
we couldn't leave dapper cadaver without
seeing one of these bodies in action
[Music]
they were kind enough to throw a stump
body off a 14 foot tall roof for us
bodies used for these purposes are
usually made from a strong dura rubber
and filled with foam or another kind of
stuffing and covered with a fabric
material this makes the bodies both
impact and tear resistant this
particular model is designed to have
some some type of swinging arm motion
but could it survive the fall
[Music]
that was cool
let's try that again
how's it look
oh just the tiniest bit off the nose on
impact everything else is perfect
one of these 100 bills is real and the
other one is a piece of prop money made
for movies
can you tell which one is which they
both have a blue security ribbon
textured ink and even the smallest
detail like text from the declaration of
independence
the answer is obvious when you flip them
over
bills as detailed as this one are
required to be blank on the other side
that's because if prop makers like prop
movie money in florida print money that
looks too real they risk getting in
trouble with the us government
that's what happened 20 years ago on the
set of rush hour 2.
money is more work than it's worth in
the long run that's greg bilson jr ceo
of the los angeles-based iss props one
of the biggest prop houses in the world
in 2000 greg got an order for and
printed 1 trillion dollars of prop money
for rush hour 2
most of which was going to be blown up
on screen and the prop money looks good
in this scene too good in fact
the fake money looked so real that some
extras on set pocketed some of it and
tried to spend it at real stores that
alerted the us secret service which
confiscated and destroyed the fake bills
and the digital files used to print them
it had cost one hundred thousand dollars
to print all of that fake money so
losing all of it was a financial blow to
greg and iss we didn't try to make fake
money to duke the public we made fake
money to make a movie but we just made
the prop too good the rush hour 2
incident underscored an obvious dilemma
for printing fake money the money needs
to look realistic on camera but it can't
look too realistic up close or people
might try to spend it in real life
the problem has become even greater in
recent years with better cameras
capturing more and more details from the
background of scenes so the prop
industry has come up with two different
types of prop money each with its own
strengths and weaknesses for scenes
where the cash is filmed from far away
productions typically use standard grade
bills
the iconic money scene from breaking bad
uses these bills which were rented from
greg and iss these bills look real from
afar
but up close are obviously fake with
lots of clear differences when compared
to the real thing
the portrait on the bill is poor quality
compared to the real one and instead of
100
it just reads 100 the smaller details on
the bill are also altered the seals are
a different design
and the signatures on the bill have been
changed then there are the obvious
additions like the prominently displayed
for motion picture use only in fact if
you zoom in to this scene from breaking
bad while it's blurry you can actually
see that each bill says for motion
picture use only
these changes should keep the secret
service away but they also mean standard
fake bills are no good for close-ups so
for those shots movies will often use
high-grade bills high-grade bills are
identical to real money but are printed
on only one side so that they can't be
confused with the real thing like the
one we showed you earlier which was
printed by rjr props in atlanta
you can see an example of a high-grade
bill in this scene from the 2014 movie
let's be cops
an alternate solution that greg and iss
have been using for the past several
years is to simply use real bills
this is the first version that they
offer iss will take a pile of completely
blank bill notes and then place one real
bill on the top of the stack and one on
the bottom making it appear as if the
entire stack is full of real bills
the second method for using real dollars
has a bigger risk attached but it may be
the best option an entire stack of real
bills
iss will get stacks of ten thousand
dollars from the bank and then deliver
them to set while having this much cash
lying around makes some productions
nervous it looks great on film and
eliminates any risk with the secret
service
that's what they did in this shot from
ozark
i see fake money used all the time and i
think it is appalling because i'm a
property master and i want things to be
authentic and accurate and look right
take a look at this season 1 episode of
girlfriends the fake looking money is
distracting to the audience
while productions may prefer to use real
money sometimes it's unavoidable like in
scenes where bills are destroyed or in
scenes that require an absurd quantity
in cases like these greg says that he
will still use fake money except he
certainly doesn't print the fake money
himself as he still has his cease and
desist from the secret service
so he buys it from prop movie money one
of the few printers that make prop money
the ultimate irony of printing prop
money is that it actually isn't very
profitable standard and high grade bills
sell for roughly 45 dollars for a stack
of 100 bills greg still has two bills
from rush hour 2 that the secret service
didn't confiscate even though these
bills look less realistic than modern
prop bills he still has them encased in
plastic so that no one can try to use
them in real life they're a physical
reminder of the risks prop makers take
and the rewards they reap to get that
perfect money shot
[Music]
what do the exorcist stand by me
blockers and big little lies have in
common a vomit scene for every
disgusting vomit scene in a movie
there's an effects team that actually
had to make the stuff and an actor who
had to sell it
hi everyone my name is ben today i'm
heading to nyspfx in red hook brooklyn
and i'm going to see how fake puke is
made for movies and tv and i couldn't be
more excited because i'm going to get to
try some of it myself grab
a snack
you might not want to eat while you
watch this
[Music]
this is mike myers a special effects
artist and the founder of nyspfx
meyers and his team created some of the
coolest practical effects for the batman
prequel show gotham and can do
everything from breakaway glass to fake
blood
but today is all about the puke which
meyers executed flawlessly in the 2015
film while we're young
[Applause]
watch the carpet fake vomit comes in all
shapes sizes and textures it can be made
to look realistic or exaggerated
depending on the scene and genre and
while we're young they used a
combination of potato leek and split pea
soup we're
attempting today uh top ramen to give
that
squiggly soft noodle projectile
nastiness to hopefully stick to
someone's lip when they're done today we
have some frozen berries that we're
going to mix up all right so here comes
the tomato paste yum
there a little color yep so we have
tomato paste or that just splashed all
over me apparently
[Music]
look how good that looks
this looks very familiar to me
but not too familiar
for this experiment we use three
different types of puke so we got
our first fake puke right there that's
peas and water and then this was a nice
mix of ramen water and uh tomato paste
and so now we've got berries right
third one is going to have berries and
water just water yeah great this is
definitely the kind of fake vomit that's
going to stain
my clothing
but i anticipated that so i wore my my
jeans that have to that have pizza on
them already so
once we had the mixtures it was time to
load them into the tubes now this stage
is actually just as important to making
convincing fake puke as the actor who
has to sell the scene the pumps that we
utilize are made for liquids not vomit
thick pasty
substances we
use our main liquid as our propellant
and then in the vertical tubes on the
pumping
incorporate the thicker paste that will
then be pushed upward and outward first
the mixture also needed to be this
texture for another reason realism the
medium density thick part of the mixture
will be fed into the top of the tubes
and the rest that comes out will be more
like liquid which meyer says follows the
pattern of real-life vomit yeah that
looks really gross
i needed a little acting advice first
when they have to like regurgitate and
and project there does have to be some
body motion involved
but it pretty much has to say if there's
my hose and if i'm regurgitating i can't
go up because then my hose is coming out
of my mouth so he has to know to only go
forward and open his mouth wide and keep
his mouth open because if he's closed
his mouth the vomit's still coming out
what a wasted take that is okay we're
gonna we're gonna do this whole bucket
yeah that's about eight gallons worth of
that's a lot we'll just chum
this is probably the chunkiest mixture
and there was going to be a lot of it in
three two one
one 102.
another one three two one
102.
i think getting the timing right is like
the first initial challenge you hear it
coming up and so like as long as you're
just kind of like you know ready to go
then then you're good to go the pea soup
mixture is different for several reasons
it's mixed with a lot of water making it
a lot more liquidy
and for this they instead use a pressure
pot with clear tubes attached
[Music]
unlike the guy in the group project that
doesn't help
but still gets an a anyways great this
hose allows you the flexibility where
you're not rigid okay cool so because
you have a guy behind you can go left
right up down turn to that camera and
splash it cool
do you want me to puke on you
you can hear you puke
once we shut it off it'll dribble
dribble dribble great cool and that
gives some authenticity because it's
also got a deflector in the front that's
going to spray
this works well for a scene involving
out of control vomiting i want to watch
out nick one piece of advice i would
give
aim away from the camera
i am covered in
fake puke and i'm not the only one for
some types of puke no rigs or hoses are
required
[Music]
a facebook and reality oh god
oh it's the shrimp
for a spit take a member of the effects
team would scoop a little bit of fake
puke up that seems like a lot the actor
would then take some into their mouth
and spit it up
like that
how did that look guys
should i do some more
actually really good there's always room
for a little improvement there any tips
you can give me for uh how to improve my
performance um well a good thing to do
with just a little more rushing a little
shoulder movement and a little try to
sell it a little more and even if uh put
your hand in front and get a little bit
more
you know separate where it's coming from
maybe a little bit coming down on
yourself all right no problem
i felt like i was in the most control i
could kind of
obviously i could time it myself i
didn't have to to
time it up with with the rig or anything
like that
uh which i think allowed me to get more
into my performance
love berries so
that spit take is is the one for me
and with no tubes to cover up nor
massive sprays to avoid the camera can
look straight onto the actor
however there are many ways to hide
these pesky tubes
sometimes they're simply taken out in
post-production other times it's all
about where you place the camera and
while cgi is used to aid the process
fake vomit scenes are still largely done
practically more work than you can
imagine goes into creating something
that in the end might just be on screen
for a couple of seconds but can still be
the most memorable moment of any given
movie or tv show
[Music]
this is a dish from the movie midsomar
i was most excited for you to come
you might think that bright yellow
center you see is an egg yolk
but it isn't see over the course of a 10
to 12 hour filming day egg yolks tend to
dry out and change color
so zoe hegedouche came up with the idea
to top some of the plates with edible
spheres made of orange and mango instead
that's a day in the life of a hollywood
food stylist
when food is involved and it's involved
in movies a lot food stylists have to
figure out how to make the food pop on
screen no matter what hurdles are thrown
at them
they're the movie's biggest problem
solvers you never think about
[Music]
the first thing a food stylist needs is
to be prepared to make a lot of food for
a lot of takes
for this scene in the amazing spider-man
the food stylist cooked 90 brand xenos
and the food stylist for 2014 chef made
800 cubano sandwiches
zoe baked over 100 pies prepared about
50 fake yolks and plated 200 real yolks
for midsomar a horror film that takes
place at the height of the swedish
midsummer festival
it's a celebration so naturally there
were a ton of food requirements
directors
they prefer not using fake things on
movies it's really important for them to
use real food so i always try like do
everything
real
these little butter churches were
actually made out of plaster and are one
of the few fake food items audiences saw
in midsomar if you're using real food
you have to make sure it tastes fresh
one of the first problems zoe had to
solve was what to do with the meat pies
which had to be edible for this shot the
movie was filmed in hungary during the
late summer months of 2018 one of the
hottest summers on record in the country
so keeping a pie filled with meat out in
the sun for a 12 hour shoot and then
asking actor jack rainer to take
multiple big bites for multiple takes
wouldn't go well and there needed to be
something inside the pie
you can't make the same size and texture
with an empty pipe for example this
shape wouldn't stay if it would be empty
the solution a filling of oatmeal mixed
with cocoa powder which is going to last
a lot longer out in the sun
oatmeal mimic the texture of ground meat
and the powder mimic the color
oatmeal is a really really good
ingredient to use on set and on camera
because you can shape it and like
color it with like edible ingredients
and make
something also that is tasty she had to
get even more creative for what would be
the toughest challenge of the entire
movie that dish with the egg yolk in the
center called the sun's eye both the
specificity of the ingredients and the
sheer amount made this dish a huge
challenge to bring to life
it's supposed to have pickled herring in
it but we didn't put it because it
wouldn't really change the look of the
dish but it would have been impossible
to use herring on that day with the heat
and like the smell that intense heat not
only dried out the yolks but it caused
some of them to burst out on the first
go-round that meant zoe and her team had
to change the dishes out every 15
minutes on top of that some of the cast
was allergic to eggs so zoey had to
completely rethink the center of the
dish instead of using yolks she made
those mango and orange edible spheres
[Music]
she put the frozen mixture into a sodium
alginate solution
where a thin membrane formed to give it
the right texture
put it next to a real egg and you can
barely spot the difference
one challenge for any movie is keeping
food that's been sitting out looking
fresh
so zoe relied on some tried-and-true
tricks of the trade she sprayed potatoes
with cooking spray to make them look
like they were fresh out of the oven she
mixed water and oil to top the egg yolk
dish which not only made it look fresher
and tastier for longer but also added
some weight to the chives which kept
getting swept away in the wind but
there's a risk of going too overboard
cooking spray looks perfect on potatoes
but if she used corn syrup instead it
would have looked too shiny in addition
she sprayed the apples with only a
couple spritzes of water
any more and they might start looking
fake
it's like just because you see some
water drops and something you you can
feel that freshness
and speaking of apples there are a ton
of them lingering in the background of
midsomar you might have noticed them in
the kitchen as danny baked pies
even this background item had to be
vetted and it wasn't as easy as picking
apples up from a store they had to look
like they were grown in the commune so
it was important to see that the apples
are
grown really close because it's
important to show that they have it in
the community where they live and it
wasn't just by
boat somewhere in the supermarket
the perfect apples for this scene
actually needed to look imperfect like
they were just plucked right off a tree
so half of them are from a nearby
farmer's market and the other half were
literally plucked off trees
you can see it's smaller
you see some like like ugly dots on it
also the most elaborate project zoe and
her team worked on was the may queen
feast they had some freedom in designing
the display
but still had to follow some important
rules
everything needed to look rustic it
needed to be traditionally swedish and
it needed to feel like it was grown
locally
so there was a lot of trial and error
one cake zoe made was rejected because
it looked too modern but this hargaman
pie shaped like a man lying in apples
met the specifications and made the cut
so did this dish made with a goat
carcass which likely would have come
from their farm
the team also did a lot of background
research like reading nordic cookbooks
to make sure everything they used was
part of scandinavian cuisine their
findings showed up on the table
they found that asparagus was used for
special occasions in sweden so they
built this asparagus tower which took
them up to five hours to construct
in the movie version the base is made up
of meatballs which helped it pass the
rustic test
crayfish center parties are swedish
tradition and the crustacean would
likely be something the commune would
find around them so the food styling
team spent around six hours building
this elaborate crayfish tower
since these displays were meant to be
consumed by the actors freshness was
less of an issue however as with the
sun's eye plate the vegetables would dry
out in the sun so zoe changed pieces out
as frequently as possible
something most chefs don't have to think
about is how their food will be filmed
zoe knew there would be a lot of shots
from high above so she made sure every
single display was really big and really
colorful
but what happens when there is a piece
of food you need and it isn't even
available in the country you're filming
in the movie needed a fresh herring for
this scene where danny attempts to eat
one whole
this moment was specifically built into
the script
it's tradition for good luck
what
herring is incredibly abundant in sweden
but the movie was filmed in hungary in
sweden you go to every market and you
just find the herring but like in
hungary i went like all the markets all
the shops and i found like smoked ones
like pickled ones but without head or it
was too small or it was too big or it
was just not not good for the movie so
the
at the end the herring had to be shipped
from france they got 20 pieces shipped
to them they were shipped at the last
minute and the team had little room for
failure the most important thing for the
scene was that actress florence pugh was
comfortable so zoe took 10 herrings and
cut and prepared the fish in multiple
styles to give florence and the
filmmakers options in the end they
landed on a fish that was boneless but
still had its head and tail they were
able to get the perfect take after seven
or eight tries
so why didn't zoe make her life easier
and get a fish she found in hungary or
just have the art department make a fake
fish that met the scene's needs
because without that real fish you
wouldn't have gotten that authentically
horrified look on florence pugh's face
and that's when going the extra mile for
your food in a movie makes it all worth
it
[Music]
in ready or not samara weaving plays the
lead role
a young bride named grace who takes part
in a deadly game of hide and seek with
her new husband's family but one of the
other big stars in the film is actually
her transforming wedding dress
which goes from this
to this
it's it's own character in the movie
really
that's costume designer avery plewis who
had to design 24 complex ever-evolving
dresses despite the fact that the
audience only ever seems to see one
dress on screen
[Music]
but first what does a costume designer
actually do basically you take the
blueprint of the script
and attach a visual identity to each
character based on what's on the page
and the director's vision this is
accomplished using things like color
composition and breakdowns of their
clothing for ready or not the dress was
supposed to symbolize grace's journey
from her happy wedding day to the brutal
bloody ending and this was no easy task
of the 24 dresses used in the production
17 were worn by samara and the other
seven were worn by her stunt double so
why so many
well the dress evolves throughout the
film
and goes through a series of five stages
based on the various things that
happened to her on top of that
each stage required at least three
multiples of each dress to shoot
different takes as co-director matt
betanelli open puts it the dress like
the story starts grand and classical
before it degrades and degrades a good
example for for me of what i was looking
at cinematically was die hard
and how bruce willis's
tank top
becomes just trashed
while it's not a wedding gown it was
sort of the same progression of
breakdown that we were going for that's
a lot of costume changes and continuity
to be aware of
which required a lot of planning i made
a flow chart like a spreadsheet
that's the other thing about costume
design that a lot of people don't
realize it's very very creative but it's
also very technical and a lot of
logistics and she worked backwards to
nail down the final designs using the
script as a guide let's take a look at
the various stages of transformation and
warning
some minor plot spoilers ahead if you
haven't seen the movie
this is the original dress you see at
the beginning of the film
it's pure white untouched and includes a
veil the look was inspired by kate
middleton's wedding dress
while it may look like one piece the
dress is actually made up of five
separate pieces
a lace top a corset a skirt a skirt
liner and a silk sash
and i did that on purpose so that when
we were on set
and they had
limited time but wanted to do several
takes we could just throw a different
skirt on her or throw a different top on
her and it would make the process faster
here's the progression of some of the
key changes to the hero dress
[Music]
early on in the film grace's dress gets
caught on the dumb waiter and she tears
the fabric transforming the gown into a
skirt this piece was made from a fabric
called tulle tulle is really easy to rip
and also looks really beautiful when
it's ripped
and the dirtier and sort of more messed
up it gets
the more interesting it looks lace was
chosen for the top because of the way
the blood would look on the material
this is also when we see her add some
ammunition and a gun to her look which
can be seen in the movie posters
now that the dress was shorter and it
was easier to run from her murderous
family
things started to get a lot darker
literally
then
she runs and falls into
the goat
carcass
world which then we dyed her dresses a
hair
darker which most people can't really
tell but that was actually a story point
to show
sort of an arc in what happens to her
five multiples of the same t-stained
yellow dress were used in this stage one
of the scenes involved harness work
which required special alterations after
she's harnessed we obviously can't use
that dress again because it's got holes
in spots where they're gonna visual
effects out the harness wires or
whatever um
and also
those dresses are usually made a size
bigger to accommodate the harnessing she
also gets shot in her hand which leads
to her tearing a sleeve off the lace top
and using it to bandage her wounds
any time she has to tear the dress as
with the skirt scene we mentioned
earlier the material is pre-cut and
stitched back on so it tears easily we
pre-rigged it samara is like a
very strong woman but there's no way she
would have been able to rip that off
basically the dress was created to be
destroyed
grace's dress gradually gets dirtier and
bloodier as she fights back against the
family
various new cuts and tears happen at
this stage like when she squeezes
through the fence the lace top is sliced
along the back and another piece of the
skirt is pulled off she also removes the
silk sash and uses it as a weapon so the
dress isn't just a visual representation
of her character it's also functional
by the end of the film grace becomes
completely drenched in blood
so the color changes once again this
time from yellow to pure red the dress
that she is covered in blood in was sort
of one of her dirtiest dresses
that we
had kind of destroyed that we had a
couple versions of we just went full
carry and dumped blood all over her we
didn't pre bloody it or anything
[Music]
one of the biggest challenges when doing
this many costume changes is continuity
you have all these things that happen to
her continuously and so tracking the
continuity is extremely
tough but the final stage when the dress
is already badly damaged and covered in
blood was actually the easiest because
it's more difficult for the viewer to
notice subtle changes while both the
character and the dress go through a
pretty horrific ordeal in the film it
has already inspired one bride who
reached out to avery to see if she could
wear the dress in her actual wedding i'm
kind of hoping that i see people
doing cosplay ready or not weddings i
think that would be pretty cool
in a recent episode of curb your
enthusiasm
larry david holds up a pack of
cigarettes
specifically morley cigarettes
now let's rewind back to 1960
and the alfred hitchcock classic psycho
take a look at the cigarettes the
psychiatrist is smoking in the final
scene of the film look
familiar morleys have appeared in
hundreds of tv shows and movies
throughout the last century in
everything from the twilight zone to
seinfeld
and to be clear
morleys are not a real cigarette brand
so
what exactly is going on here
is this some deep secret connected
cinematic universe that ties norman
bates to george costanza
if you pay really close attention to
shows and movies you'll start to notice
many of the same objects over and over
again
like this newspaper
there are several fake brands that cross
over into other works
including acme oceanic air and heisler
beer
but one of the most reused brands is
morley
morley cigarettes is the most prominent
brand of fictional cigarettes that has
been used for the past 60 years in films
television shows and video games
jonathan koontz says they come from a
company in sun valley california the
earl hayes press is a 100 year old prop
house that supplies fake brand props to
hollywood and they are the main
suppliers of morley cigarettes according
to its website earl hayes press pretty
much sells fake everything
from chips and beer to magazines and
license plates
morley's design is based on the most
popular real cigarette brand in the
united states marlborough
with its signature red and white
packaging come to where the flavor is
come tomorrow country
marlboros are often nicknamed marlies
hence the fake name morley
earl hayes press sells morleys in a few
different varieties including morley
lights as you can see here
but to understand why morley even exists
in the first place
we have to go back and take a look at
the love-hate relationship between
tobacco companies and hollywood what's
that winston cigarettes
try one granny they use first rate in
the 1950s you mostly had sponsors for tv
and radio where the advertising agencies
paid for and produced the show
the characters even used the same
products
and many of these early advertisers were
you guessed it tobacco companies i love
lucy was famously sponsored by philip
morris
so you would see brand integrations like
this have you tried to phillip morris
lately you'll love them they're so
smooth and mild and they taste so good
movies were also typically
cross-promoted with tobacco companies
here's joan crawford for example
smoking chesterfield cigarettes in a
poster promoting her film flamingo road
if a show wasn't sponsored
it would use a fake brand instead since
it wasn't getting paid to show the real
brand
enter morley this fake brand can be
traced all the way back to episodes of
perry mason
and one of the most memorable horror
movies of all time psycho
although the box shows an earlier white
design as opposed to the newer red and
white version
and i think this is what really started
the morley cigarettes craze
morley's popped up in tv shows like
naked city and the twilight zone
most famously nightmare at twenty
thousand feet with william shatner
lighting up a morley on a plane
but morleys weren't used as much during
the 1970s and 1980s
why for one the 1970 public health
cigarette smoking act banned cigarette
ads from airing on television and radio
this was part of a big push to stop
smoking in tv shows and the appearance
of cigarettes on tv decreased in general
around this time by about 70 percent
tobacco companies turn to movies instead
paying big bucks to have their
cigarettes appear in popular films
throughout the 80s
so there wasn't much of a need for fake
brands like morley in movies either but
this all changed again in 1998 with
what's known as the master settlement
agreement
which banned tobacco advertising in both
films and tv
paving the way for the fake brand's
triumphant return
[Music]
the real explosion of morley cigarettes
in popularity in pop culture comes at
the end of the 1990s in the x-files well
you'll be interested to know that morley
tobacco has painted all of our files on
the case
in the show the cigarette smoking man is
a villainous character played by william
davis he famously smoked morley's and
the fake tobacco company was actually
incorporated into the plot in the
episode called brand x
something you couldn't do very easily
with a real brand but more on that in a
bit following the x-files morally
started showing up everywhere
even in video games and music videos
it has literally appeared in hundreds of
movies and television shows
here's george smoking a pack in seinfeld
and chandler holding a pack in an
episode of friends they're also found in
justified and the 2019 breaking bad
movie el camino
shows technically have the freedom to
show real brands these days for
historical realism as long as it's not a
paid ad lucky strikes
is toasted
so why would they opt for a made-up
brand from the 60s
well
real brands are a big risk there are
several reasons why film and tv
producers would avoid
using real brand names without
permission there is a little bit of
legal jeopardy if your product is used
to kill somebody or is defamed in any
way you might be subject to lawsuits
a study found that villains are the ones
who are typically depicted smoking in
films and tv and brands likely do not
want their image associated with
criminals
apple for instance reportedly doesn't
let villains use its products in movies
real products are typically covered up
or disguised when used in shows or
movies
in the 1930s and 40s the brand letters
on cars and films were carefully removed
hollywood was quite careful to keep
brand names out of their films they
didn't want to be associated with any
particular product line and they didn't
want offend the people that were using a
rival product so these days morleys are
mainly used as the replacement brand
an inside joke similar to those 555
phone numbers and the wilhelm scream
morally cigarettes have become almost
like a meme on the web something where
you can kind of wink your eye at the
audience and say you know we know that
you know that this is really a movie or
a television show and we're just kind of
playing with things
ask your id yeah i think i have it this
might be the most famous fake id in any
movie
so famous that someone tried to use it
as a fake id in real life that's why
prop makers have to be extra careful
when making fake ids for movies and tv
shows too good and they could get into
legal trouble we stopped by the hand
prop room in la which made the mclovin
id and the studio of graphic props
artist ross mcdonald to see how
hollywood makes its prop ids
when creating fake ids for production
agencies might limit their customers to
major studios it's the prop maker's job
to make these ids look as real as
possible on screen without crossing into
any legal gray areas like with this new
mexico's driver's license which the hand
prop room made for black widow the photo
of scarlett johansson has been swapped
in for a stock photo and the hologram
which in real ids would be 3d is
actually 2d there's a lot of tricks that
you can use in the graphic itself to
make it look like it's catching light
and having some shine to it for a
special close-up they might simulate the
hologram physically using a silk screen
and iridescent powders mixed with clear
ink
luckily according to graphic props
artist ross mcdonald simplifying
elements like holograms and shadow
images can make the id look better on
screen since it won't be as jammed with
tiny details the rule of thumb is
convincing is better than accurate to
nail the aesthetics prop makers often
focus on the sheen of the id a lot of
the driver's licenses you see especially
now have this kind of map but also a bit
of a sheen look and that's what we're
going to get from the lamination process
laminating will also give it the weight
of an actual driver's license so that
when the actor holds the card it not
only looks but feels like the real deal
for projects that call for close-ups
they use this old-school embossing
machine to make sure the lighting
reflects off the numbers on the card in
the right way and for special forms of
id like those for the us army the prop
makers might have to mimic metal chips
for these prop artists can make fake
chips out of vinyl to stick on top of
the id or they can print it on a card
that already has the fake chip built in
but specialized ids pose another problem
they're often very very plain military
id cards police identification even the
fbi identification they're meant to be
looked at really close up but on a tv
screen they might be sort of holding it
up and we're looking at them from eight
feet away as a prop artist you'd maybe
spice things up with a flashy gold badge
or this type of giant fbi logo you see
popping up a lot in shows and movies a
lot of times the frame of reference that
viewers have is other shows the x-files
one
is one that you see copied a lot the id
also needs to play well in the scene
f
b
i
like this 1920s one ross made for a
prohibition agent in boardwalk empire he
first produced an id faithful to what
agents carried at the time but after
some rehearsals the filmmakers asked him
to add space for a badge inside so the
agents would have something to flash
things get tricky when it comes to
passports which are generally much
harder to forge than id cards because of
all the detail involved across multiple
pages to make a current us passport the
hand prop room has to print and trim the
pages do a clear overlay on the photo
page and silkscreen the cover to give it
that authentic sheen
after sewing the pages together the prop
makers assemble the passport and do a
final trim
to avoid legal troubles prop houses will
sometimes deliberately alter the look
like on this netherlands passport for
madam secretary the show's legal team
asked the hand prop room to make the
passport less accurate by reshuffling
the layout and changing the color scheme
with historical ids legality isn't an
issue so prop artists can get a lot more
authentic on period shows that's what
ross did when he made this 1920s
passport for steve buscemi's character
on boardwalk empire passport
ross first had to track down a 1921
passport to use as a model then
digitally clear out the existing info
and recreate the background pattern so
that he could go in and write the new
material on top he had to find the red
legal seal in europe since the us
doesn't use that kind anymore then
emboss the seal and photo make print and
perforate the stick on stamps and
recreate all the rubber stamps to match
those of the time period he was lucky to
have an example to work with it can be a
lot harder to find reference material
for more mundane forms of id like a
driver's license from a specific year
and state especially from
pre-1980 there's no reason for anyone to
digitize that for this one the closest
reference ross could find was a photo of
a new jersey license from 1923. he
scanned it and built all this type on
top of it in the computer to recreate a
high-res version since this stuff is so
hard to find ross keeps folders of all
the reference materials he's compiled
through the hundred plus movies he's
worked on when he's working off a
pixelated photo like this one the
hardest part is recreating the actual
document part of the id ross has to
identify all the typeface so he places
different fonts over the original text
to find ones that match
it helps to have a library of antique
fonts used in different time periods you
can date this particular cutting of this
font to between 1815 and roughly 1825.
sometimes though you have to recreate a
whole alphabet for this 1960 passport
made for an unreleased project jacob
scanned six or seven real passports from
the era to capture every letter of the
alphabet then cleaned up the letters and
vectorized them to make a whole new font
just for this particular year of
passports his team also had to recreate
by hand the blue to red effect of this
special 60s stamp
replicating the look of old printing
tools takes some creative problem
solving the hand prop room used printing
tricks on the 67 california license for
chris pine's character and i am the
knight to make the text look like it
came out of a typewriter
whenever possible it helps to use the
real deal ross prints all kinds of seals
and typefaces on his old school
letterpress which is operated by a foot
pedal
then there's the question of what to
write ross made these illinois licenses
for a scene where the police raid a
packed speakeasy which meant a bunch of
background characters needed to show id
so ross had to make up a bunch of names
addresses exact heights weights and more
after about the tenth one you're like
did i use john smith already
ross will often refer to period
yearbooks for names that sound old
school this guy's aloysius so wiki and
for main characters all this info needs
to be confirmed with production these
are passport instructions for owen
sleeder in boardwalk empire providing
details like the character's full name
and hair color but leaving out other
pertinent information a lot of other
documentation requires things like birth
dates they you know the writers have
never even considered how old the
character is or what his birthday is at
the end of the day though graphic prop
artists like ross and jacob don't always
know how the prop will be used when
they're creating it sometimes these
props are highlighted in the action
but sometimes you're doing a lot of
research and work for an id that may
only be flashed on screen for a split
second so incredibly elaborate prop
which we see in the episode like this he
just hands it across the counter
believe it or not there's a blacksmith
in hollywood who specializes in making
real swords for films and tv
yes actual swords for stars and stunt
actors alike to cut slice and swing at
each other
sure in some instances rubber swords are
used like when an actor does stunts that
require falling
but as high definition video has
improved using authentic looking swords
has become more important
it needs to be real so you can go in
close you can see it it also if an actor
picks up a sword he has that tactile
feedback of the sword in his hand and
working with it as opposed to holding a
baton and emulating on a green screen
what's supposed to be happening so it
makes a big difference
jack sparrow blade zorro peter pan and
countless other movie stars use a sword
as their weapon of choice but to achieve
an authentic look plastic or rubber
swords simply won't do
forget about a prop house these swords
are created in a real blacksmith shop
the authenticity and speed with which
these swords are made can only be done
by a real blacksmith like tony swatin
i'm a smith i'm a blacksmith i'm a
bladesmith i'm a silversmith i also work
in copper and tin i hit things with a
hammer so that's basically my job swords
made from real metal being heated
beaten
grinded
beaten some more quenched
and polished all for on-screen accuracy
for over 30 years tony's been making
iconic weapons and armor in his shop
sword and the stone
he has over 200 feature films and tv
shows under his belt
legend of zorro and the mask of zorro i
made the principal swords for antonio
banderas for zorro i did pirates of the
caribbean i did pirates one two and
three and four
he worked on the sword and that
throwable glaive thingy for blade
as well as
[Music]
i worked on hook i made the hook for the
movie hook as well as the swords and
background swords
i know it's not a sword but he did the
hook from hook and that's pretty cool
it starts with production sharing their
sword needs and working with the
blacksmith on the design it's also
crucial to decide what the sword will be
made from
a lot of times a film will contact me
and say hey we we have a movie it's a
12th century scotland and we need to
make a sword what would you recommend or
this is our design how would you go
about making it we kind of work together
with the prop master the costume
designer the set decorator and the
production designer a lot of times i'll
have a input into what we make zoro's
sword case in point it was actually a
curved hunting sword from the 1500s
that was in the tower of london and the
wallace collection in london and i
cobbled those together and made it into
a more of a rapier then shortened that
down and embellished it with details
from both swords
once the design is decided multiple
versions of the same sword will be
created depending on how the sword will
be used on screen
a more authentic real steel sword is
needed for close-up action shots while
an aluminum sword will be used for wider
shots and sequences that require more
movement
this is the hero
jack sparrow sword this is formed out of
steel forged steel hill to ebony grip
this
is not a hero piece this is a background
piece this is a stunt weapon this one
feels way lighter it is way lighter the
hero piece is out of forged steel for
the hilt and ebony for the grip this is
identical from here down
the blade is identical looking at it
going up here but this is made out of
aluminum this
is an aluminum rapier it's lightweight
it's dull it's not going to cut anyone
but it has great properties
it comes back to true i don't know i
flinched there i was like
the sword starts as layers of dissimilar
metal welded together in this instance
some of the layers are made from an
industrial band saw blade originally
used to cut down redwood trees
yo
the metal is heated up then hammered
flat either by hand or power hammer
then fold it over and flattened a few
more times
[Music]
the sword is ground down to its shape
and is heat treated in an electric oven
this process brings a blade up to 1600
degrees
and then it's quenched in oil
this hardens the steel without this step
the blade will crack or shatter while in
use
after that more grinding and polishing
tony also makes the grip hilt and pommel
it's all put together and voila you have
a sword
seen here my guy brian swings the real
sword its weight and authenticity makes
for a realistic looking swing and action
you can only get with a real sword
in case you couldn't tell this is a
pretty dangerous environment everything
is either hot sharp or poisonous
notice i'm not in any of these shots
that's because i'm behind the cameraman
what makes me unique is the speed at
which i can create these pieces i'll put
a 35 swords together in a day for
film production the most swords that
i've made for a single production is
probably got to be last samurai i made
about 600 swords predominantly aluminum
weapons for the big battle scenes but
the crazy thing about that i was working
on both master and commander and pirates
of the caribbean concurrently
so between
those three productions he did a
thousand swords and with that tony's
ability as a blacksmith the speed
authenticity and the detail with which
he can create swords is impossible to
duplicate
[Music]
so
[Music]
you